the other day in Cleveland OH there was
a bra that went on you know when you're
playing a sport trying to feed your
family you're around the boys all day
every day for eight months things just
kind of boil or it could be anything
right that was kind of crazy I would
have been the Umpire he started in there
and he backed out of there he was out of
there quick
you guys can have it ta is my boy he got
him you know what I'm saying he just got
got we had a team meeting about it
players only we said if if someone gets
knocked out on the field there is no way
that there is not enough nothing thrown
after that no one fought after you got
to protect your boy right if there is a
fight that breaks out with us I love you
guys to death I'm just gonna be pulling
people out of there so that's that's our
agreement if we ever brawl we'll come
hold each other back
truce